and again many people are seen doing
this even in um Hindu dance you see a
lot of this and it's supposedly awakens
the crown chakra which is the snake
exactly so 666 snake wow all interated
all inter
related what's up everybody thank you
for joining us at LED live we have an
awesome show with our special guest
blessings when she's going to tell us
about how she used to be a licensed
certified practitioner teacher of yoga
and meditation and all these things and
just where that Journey has taken her
what she's found out about that whole
Lifestyle the whole practice that
millions of people are being sucked into
I mean you see this stuff everywhere so
if you're the type of person that
believes like I don't do all that
spiritualistic stuff and all I do is
just the exercise and stuff this is a
show for you please stay to the end
you're not going to want to miss this
that's right absolutely so just to start
out I think I should definitely make a a
personal statement and that is that my
goal is not to offend anyone um you know
I was a practitioner I was sucked into
yoga I was devoted uh to the practice I
didn't understand that there was a
spiritual component to it I thought that
it was just exercise I didn't see a
problem as a Christian doing it and I
didn't see it as the problem if you were
secular and you weren't Christian I just
didn't see that there was anything to be
worrisome about and so it's really
important that I that I make that
personal statement that this is not a a
picking on um yoga or its roots of
Hinduism this is just more of an
informational um uh package so that
people who are partaking in it
understand what they're stepping into
because it's not what they're being told
there's a lot of of undisclosed
information that you need to know and I
believe in a God that practices informed
consent amen my God the Creator Yahweh
he does not say to anyone you are my
servant um and and it's that way or no
way he says you have moral autonomy you
have the right to look at this Doctrine
you have the right to accept it or you
have the right to walk away from it and
not so in the Demonic realm and so we're
going to go into that um if you're
eating something and I know you're
allergic to nuts and I say look it's on
the package right here nuts I'm doing
that out of love not because I want to
hurt your feelings you really like that
brownie I don't care how much you like
it I want to tell you that there's
something harmful in here no and this is
again it's not to attack you know where
Hinduism comes from it's not to attack
India or Indian people I love Indian
people I loved my time in India I love
how sweet natured there are they are uh
this is about a practice I and a a
religion or a cult that's dis that's
disguised as a religion and something
that's good for you and it's something
that can lead you to quote unquote
salvation but self- Salvation and and
it's not true so honestly if I had been
given the information at the front end
of my contract I would have had an
informed consent to participate
unfortunately none of that was presented
to me everything that I was given was
diluted and basically
bastardized so that I was left
blindfolded and walking in obedience to
something that I had no idea was demonic
wow and again this is not an offense to
the culture or the group or people um
this is about the spiritual side of yoga
and what it really is about so we need
to be able to separate those two and
you're not pointing the finger at others
this no this is my own experience this
is my story you don't have to agree I'm
just giving you information that wasn't
given to me even though I spent time at
ad Asam um spent thousands of dollars to
get these degrees and ayurveda and
therapeutic yoga in aanga yoga in bam
not beam excuse me in in um poana mutasa
in um what else Ashtanga did I say that
um therapeutic yoga aenar yoga um you
know
I did not at any point get the
information that I'm about to give to
you and the reason this is important is
because a lot of people are licensed to
show you or instruct you in yoga but
they themselves don't understand what
they're teaching because it is it is
almost created like a bar class that's
kind of how they're teaching it devoid
of the real practice the veiled
experience that comes with it and so
it's very important because you could be
the reason to lead someone into mental
illness um depression anxiety through
yoga through yoga there are there's
research there's lots of pseudo science
involved in yoga and most of it is
unproven it's just a way to get the
western side interested in it yeah right
and so you hear things like oh if you do
you know plow pose it's going to you
know help with your thyroid function
plow pose is a pose where you bring your
legs over your head and um what it in in
effect it it cuts off the circulation to
your thyroid gland and so the yoga
philosophy westernized philosophy is
that you're cutting off circulation to
your thyroid gland so that you can Purge
out the bad blood cells and when you
release the bind right that position and
you go back to normal all this new blood
rushes in and invigorates invigorates
the endocrine system the thyroid but
it's actually not true yoga is actually
a practice for death oh wow it is a
practice again for death because life is
in the blood and life is circulation yes
I mean I don't know yeah I don't know if
a lot of practices ever would teach you
to cut off the
circulation that's interesting so so
again and it's also something that in in
India when I was in India my time there
you
know the Indian people really looked at
us B like bewildered like this is a
bizarre situation like you come here
wanting Enlightenment we don't even
practice this stuff like we don't even
do this we don't want no parts of this
you know like they believe there's a
direct spiritual connection yes you know
can separate you cannot separate it but
in the western world they're like well
I'm just stretching and this particular
there was a guest in our show uh he was
uh um from India from India yoga
instructor Ian I know I and so he he was
saying that they they would feel
offended over there AB because they're
like this is like you said this is our
religion and um I remember cuz I edited
this video you were saying like it's
like someone coming into the Christian
World saying I want to be baptized but I
don't believe in your God or anything
I'm just going to yeah I just like the
ritual yeah so like that doesn't make
sense doesn't and like you just said
that they saw stuff people doing things
that even they wouldn't do yeah we had a
guest one time she was the same same
story uh got into yoga which led to
meditation she had led to ascended
masters and all these things and she
said she saw a website Pro website not
not anti yoga it was all about cundalini
and and she said at the very top it had
these snakes and this big warning about
cundalini is dangerous and this was from
people who are teaching it they're
saying if you practice this be prepared
for strange things that happen to your
body and mind and everything well the
sad thing is that it's not just
Kundalini like um it's yoga period and
and so teachers you know instructors
they're given this this class kind of a
syllabus you know ex exercise a or or I
shouldn't say exercise but they think it
is pose a to pose Z you need to get
through this in an hour or an hour and a
half format and that's it talk a little
bit about feelings you know they teach
you chance you don't really know what
you're chanting you know um you don't
understand all of it right you don't
understand the emptying your mind so
we're going to get into all of that so A
really you know so that's you this is
these are all pictures of me in the
practice so um I was definitely very
devoted and and this is going into um
this was my first day at my school and
the school I don't want to plug you know
but it was a blank School of medit yoga
and meditation and the two main main
teachers there one of them um his name
was Mahesh and Mahesh is a prominent
name in The Meditation world and it is
said that his great great great
grandfather I believe was the Maharishi
Mahesh who basically taught how to get
into Transcendental Meditation so this
is three generations using yoga to get
there using the methodology of pan
jali's eight limb path we'll get into
that so I'm here and the reason ended up
here is because again I was teaching um
at all the prominent the the high-end
clubs so like your Club sport Equinox um
the
studio um Yoga Works you know I was the
one of the teachers to this day if you
look me up online you're going to see
you know blessings win or blessings
Robertson win and it's going to
immediately take you to yoga and I was a
very sought-after teacher I'm not
patting my back I'm just you know
telling you how deep I was into these
things yeah you're a credible source to
talk about this right question that
green book I see that stick with a snake
wrapped around we see this we see this
in medical logos what is
that yes and so there's there's two ways
to look at it it's Al it's the serpent
that healed you know UMES exactly
Moses's staff that healed the people who
had been bitten by the snake but then
it's also been taken in in the Gnostic
world and it's it's it it represents um
secret knowledge it's a rebranding yes
yeah I'll tell you that Moses uh the the
rod with the serpent on there in Moses
day didn't have two and it didn't have
wings that's ausus when you look it up
that's um Mercury holds that in his hand
and it says that he's the guide of
the he he's the the god of the
underworld yeah the god of the
underworld he heals the the wicked
people and stuff like he's the guide of
the Dead on his helmet yeah and the so
these are some of the textbooks that are
on my table this and this this uh yoga
journal was actually made by my yoga
Guru at the time that I was under um and
that would be the Kundalini shaki okay
so she is representative of that serpent
that you see the two serpents right so
one is shaki and one is Shiva and you
you want the Kundalini energy to rise up
your spine which leads to
starts in your crotch area yes so we'll
get into this we'll get into this that's
really what saying I want to add I
wanted to describe what that is because
I I didn't have much train of thought
but that's the caducus held by Mercury
and it says that he's the god or the
guide of the Dead Protectors of liars
Merchants thieves like these are it's a
protector of wicked and the guide of the
dead right and they're using the
beginning stage of your sexuality to
your mind yes and it's like it's very
purposeful it's it's very perverted um
so you'll see some of the we'll get into
this but this is just like a a synopsis
kind of like this is a day in the life
of me in yoga I think it's interesting
that there so much serpents in it
serpents behind the Shiva serpents on
here and it's all about inviting the
serpent to your crown chakra and and
that might not sound alarming but we as
Christians do have a a higher vantage
point we we know who that serpent is and
see all around the world people are
worshiping dragons and serpents and
things like that right your face and the
thing to remember is that there is the
gospel and then there is the counterfeit
gospel and God is the Creator and when I
say God I like to point out that I'm
talking about Yahweh I'm not talking I'm
talking about ruach I am not talking
about any other God Shiva you know
Buddha none of that um and what he does
is he takes what whatever God has and he
just perverts it the shakina of Glory
which we are the temple of God right so
this body is really designed in a sort
of way that the Jewish temple was laid
out that the that the most holy place
was literally the place and seat of God
yes and it's very interesting to me that
there's a snake that wants to sit in the
very seat of your God yes in the Holy
the the highest and and and the holiest
of holy
so this is um where the journey really
starts to take a turn so basically I was
um a a very pronounced teacher very you
know well-known teacher back in the Bay
Area and um a friend of mine was saying
oh I'm going to do a cleanse you know
and you know 7-Day Adventist we're into
health and healing and cleansing so I
was like sure I'll you know I'll do it
with you and I get introduced to this
system called Poncha Karma Poncha means
five karma meaning the the works and the
things that you can do to cleanse or to
rid um your body of and so the the
ayurvedic practi
practitioner um said to me I really you
know like that you understand you know
the yoga postures and she's saying it in
a way that I think she assumed because I
was reading up on it but and able to
discuss it with her but I don't think
she understood that I didn't know the
source oh but says to me but you need
real training you need authentic
training and so she says I want you to
go and learn where I learned and so she
recommended this school and that's how I
ended up at the ashram because she
wanted to hire me on her staff to be
able to prescribe yoga and ayurvedic
medicine to her you know clients in
California she wanted you to go to India
right so I go feeling honored you're
like oh a doctor thought so well of me
like you know so I'm like let's do this
so I leave my family and I go to India
for two months and I end up at this
ashram and this is a yoga Shala so all
of our um classes were held between this
yoga Shala and another yoga Shala and um
this is basically a holy place and what
you can't see is that there are deities
on some of these there's one here
there's another here here here um and
even those weren't alarms to me because
honestly they're ubiquitous in our
culture you go to a furniture store you
can pick it up you know yeah like I'm in
another country and this is what they
believe so you dismiss it and that's the
thing too is that I really think we
should be careful as um Travelers what
we bring back home this is so true and I
have this really weird short Real World
Experience my parents were missionaries
when they first got married and I
remember we had a fish tank and we had a
big huge like library and they had
brought in home a Buddha and the Buddha
was sitting by the fish tank and we kept
killing the fish in the fish tank and it
was really
and I remember thinking as a k I always
like why why do they have this God
that's sitting there on the Shelf kind
of
interesting and then this is my class
schedule and um it basically shows you
all of the training that I went through
all the different disciplines and if you
you'll take note 5:45 a.m. I have to be
in that yoga Shala and at that time I do
something called karma yoga and so they
believe there's when you say yoga this
is another misconception people have
when you say yoga people think it's just
the ASA the posture practice it's not
yoga has several different branches of
of of Rights and rituals the meditation
the sort of the karma yoga sweeping up
making sure it's clean so can I point
this out yes what if people had this
kind of tenacity with religion I agree
100% studing the Bible or something like
this 100% you know what I mean where
where would we be if we people oh
whatever you guys are just you know
making a big deal about it or you want
us to study the Bible all day yeah
people do this all day and I think it's
really important to point out that
people are comfortable Society is
comfortable trashing Christians for
their beliefs and their
Doctrine um they're very critical even
amongst ourselves we'll say I'm not
practicing Christianity because so and
so was was not Christian what treated me
poorly but in reality there's so many
other Rel rels and so many different
adher to those religions and no one ever
comes for those people for being bad
within that religion they think it's
cool and they're like oh good job you
know being so devoted yeah and there's
no criticism if there's respect but
Christianity you get pushed back if
somebody doesn't adhere to the schedule
they don't like oh I'm not going to be a
yogas because this or whatever yeah yeah
so we had karma karma yoga ASA practice
ASA means actually doing the physical
Pro uh um uh yoga and then at 8:15 we
would have breakfast but during
breakfast it's not peaceful because
you're studying you know you're scarfing
food and you're you're literally doing
your assignments and it's just really
it's almost like medical school like no
joke cred into it's super crammed and
it's all new you know it's not anything
you even have heard of you don't really
know this stuff um and then you go into
ayurveda which is the sister science of
yoga and it's basically nature worship
and using herbs and plants to heal you
and then Yoga Nidra at 10:00 to 11:15
you'll see that slash Yoga Nidra is a
meditation style where basically you're
um introduced to hypnosis wow um and
then teaching
practicum uh at 11 you see teaching
practicum AA methodology this is where
they start to instead of you doing the
postures then they they have you sit and
they start to open up the literature to
you but the Lit Literature is redacted
it it does not have all the the deities
and the dark you don't get any of that
and then they have what's called non-
contct hours from 2:30 to 4: and so this
is you being emus this is self-isolation
and that's really key to the practice of
yoga because people who practice the the
actual true yogis traditionally they
would remove themselves from society
become Hermits Aesthetics yes and they
would just be by themselves and then
4:15 you start at and again even the
names shaki White Hall shaki is the
Kundalini serpent um 4:15 you start
pranayama and this is a breathing
practice this is how you control the
breath okay and that's super important
because you don't have to do yoga the
physical yoga you could do the yoga
breathing and still get the Kini is that
is that what we keep seeing popping up
the breath work yep breath that's
basically connected to yoga that's
absolutely what it is but it's not
isolated to uh Hinduism you find it in
all cultures you even find it in wika so
when they're casting their spells they
don't just say you know Alakazam alak
kazum or I don't know what their spells
are but they say it with intention and
they say it with breath so it has to be
like int I and breathy because there's
power there's life in the breath and
when you think of this what did God do
to animate us that's right he breathes
so what does Satan do he perverts the
breath so then you go to a small break
then you go to yoga philosophy and this
is where you're introd introduced to pan
jali's yoga sutras and so he was
considered the modern father the father
of modern yoga um 6:00 p.m to
6:45 this is meditation and they would
we would have a roving cycle um ban Shri
Raj NES was a famous actually say
Infamous Yogi who came to the United
States after being kicked out of India
because his practices in meditation were
inducing you know demonic spirits orgies
and things like that he took over part
of Oregon and almost succeeded in like
having this whole Community take over a
a segment of of a
a sex cult yeah it was it was a drug sex
cult there's a documentary about it I'm
not making the stuff up you can find it
ban sh rajish he's also known as
Osho so um the reason it says bring your
FL flashlight is because you're walking
home in the in the dark and so you know
you're you're in this this is a
lifestyle then on Saturdays God's holy
Sabbath I would be waking up at 6:15
going to do Karma Yoga again sweet
sleeping and which which they make you
work interesting yes they make you work
on the day that the Lord says rest
interesting and then you're ready again
to do your ASA and so you do Asa from
6:30 to 8:35 again that's the physical
form of yoga and then the rest of the
day you spend studying Sunday is what
they call holiday but you really don't
have a day off because if you take
holiday you'll be backlogged and you
won't be ready it's the day of the sun I
was about to say I find that really
interesting that because because Sun
worship is huge in yoga right toward the
sun um and so like if you look in
history you can find this that back in
the day after the Jews you know and
Gentiles came together and became
Christians the Sabbath was still kept
according to the Ten Commandments even
in Africa right right exactly and and so
then eventually uh it was the Roman
power in collaboration with the Roman
Catholic Church church that started
introducing Sunday Sunday was more
popular Sabbath wasn't as popular and
boom things was Constantine was he was
Christian he was converted but he still
was sympathetic toward the people who
worshiped the pagans the pagans all so
he just did it
toase both parties and convert the
pagans so to speak and so it's
interesting that we have that history of
the Sun and
Sunday and you see it here again Sunday
is the day that is kept even in in yoga
one day you get and they make you work
like there's no other work any other day
six days but on Sunday yeah so that was
our rigorous schedule every day and this
is basically basically how I can
introduce you to how what was actually
happening in the background of my study
which was that I was opening portals so
this is a photo of me um walking through
these doors um you would have to walk
through this path in order to get to one
of the places that we would study and so
this colorful Myriad is kind of like if
you could visualize um the path to
Enlightenment there's all these colorful
things there's all these distractions
but somewhere in the end you're going to
get enlightened don't worry just keep
going just keep going right all the
shock trist like imagery yes nothing is
you know by chance you know everything
is very very specific um intentional and
then this is one of their
ayurvedic um spas that you could go to
and so you could get these treatments
and so people go um to India to this
particular part because ayurveda the
pseudo science part is is is at
top-notch level here it was invented
here so these these centers are there
for people who maybe aren't coming for
yoga but they're coming for relaxation
so does that like the cupping and all
that kind of stuff is all looked into
that it's it's um the the Poncha karma
that's acupuncture that's Chinese
traditional yeah um but the this is more
like for Poncha Karma the five different
types of cleansings and and in in the
yoga sutras um they talk a lot and the
the G is it called the Ganda samita they
talk a lot about cleansing there's a lot
of ritual cleansing and to them it's
really important and so there's a lot of
manipulation that goes on um to the
rectum and so um there are very wild
bizarre rituals for cleansing
specifically that area so things like
putting a turmeric stock up there and
manipulating it and or getting into a
one of the the holy rivers and um
sucking in the water and pushing it out
like basically doing an enema repeatedly
there's a lot of manipulation to that
zone of the body because they consider
it one of the gate ways to shaki so
remember the dormant snake is down there
because a lot of the rituals in the
Pagan um religions dating all the way
back to Egypt there was this belief that
you know the rectum and uh was a place
of of um access or a portal to
Enlightenment wow that's so strange and
there were a lot of um homosexual um
orgies and things of that nature as part
of the rights and the systems for like
bail worship alist Crowley when he would
do um satanic ritualistic M magic and
when he was writing um sex blood magic
he found that they he would go through
these lengthy um things to get people um
do rituals to get the demons in and then
if he actually just brought into this
circle some other male and did some
homosexual act it was like cutting a
shortcut rather than doing all those
things to the Demonic world right it's a
direct source instead of just doing the
other things yeah wow and that's why he
participated in that he was a uh very
upfront bisexual um because he said that
that gave him power so interesting that
that God specifically says like there's
not a lot God says about sex in the
Bible he says don't doality don't do
homosexuality and don't do it from the
behind and so it's like God they they
they have this counterfeit religion
where oh you can find Enlightenment here
but then we're going against everything
the Bible right and that that is true
and and the other thing is that people
like to focus on it being man and man
but when God says don't do sodomy that
means don't do that to a woman either
right agree it's not just male on male
it's it's that act period we have a
podcast called the little life Studios
podcast and in season one I talked to a
married couple he is a physician and she
is a therapist and I asked them any
question under the son about what the
Bible says about sex and he's very clear
from a medical perspective it is
unhealthy it is bad for you you should
not practice this even if you're not a
Christian he said there's so many
medical reasons why you should not be
involved in this and they're pretty
obvious it's a one way and that muscle
once it's gone there's nothing really
you can do to rejuvenate that muscle so
you're looking at a life of diapers all
right so this is some of the uh
coursework to give you um an impression
of what types of Yoga I had to learn so
Aang
asanga is known as Raja yoga and that is
an eight Lim path um and you can see
that on the far left there's several
different series that go into it you
know sequence a with Sera namaskara
which is what you were talking about the
sun worship um and that would cover
these first two pages this one is the
menstrual Series so um this is supposed
to eleviate pain if a woman is going
through PMS having um cramps and then
there's the poan hanana mutasa series
and so I had to learn learn three
different versions of this series and
this is more on the therapeutic side and
all of it has to do with breath and this
one is more focused on the joints so
it's very minute movements um but
centered Focus it's something that they
call dristy it's your concentration and
it's small subtle movements and then um
that would be these two and then this is
for my ayurvedic
aenar um training and this was learning
how to do sequences specific for a
disease so I had a client who had
psoriasis and so I had to create my own
sequence and so you'll see that I start
with um saasa you can't really see it
completely here which is a corpse pose
you lie on the floor as if you're dead
there's symbology and there's reason for
that because it's The Reincarnation myth
and then you go into the chanting and
then um here you teach people how to to
breathe and um you know each sequence
basically would take someone and
supposedly cure them from having
psoriasis um so question because some of
these poses it's like that kind of a
stretch is a really nice stretch if
you're like working out like crazy it's
not necessar the the pose that is
necessarily the problem right no so
there's a difference context yeah
there's you know the body is made to
move the body does need stretching the
the body does need exercise it is fine
to stretch a lot of a lot of these poses
are similar to the ones that you would
find in gymnastics or ballet or just
your general gym fitness class you know
um but the problem is that when they are
um put in this particular
sequence and under the construct of yoga
it is a a nonverbal language to the
spirit realm and it is a Devotion to the
whole Pantheon of their of their gods
and their deities so what if somebody
says what if I just do something out of
sequence just one like for example I saw
the leg raises I do leg raises
for no I mean this this has this is
literally there's a breath there's a
prayer there's a chant there's a so
there's a method with it that comes with
it it's not necessarily that I just bent
over and touch my toes like you're not
going to get possessed just doing
regular stretching so so what if what if
um you I just ask the right questions
for someone who might be watching what
if somebody says well I'm going to do
this particular pose I'm into yoga but
I'm not doing all the chanting and
everything like you just said I just
want to do it for the sake of the
stretching yeah so we're going to get
into that we're going to get into that
because again there's there's difference
there's a difference between the
stretches that you would do for normal
physical you know relief from tight
muscles and then there's this this
prescription and this is a a a worship
and a
prescription so these are some of the
textbooks that um we were um trained in
ASA again is is um the physical practice
mudra is when they do everything with
their hands so there's these hand
signals right that's mudra all of this
is sign language the spirit realm and
then yogic management of common diseases
this tells you you know they believe
that people are we're not created by God
of creation from we're created from
Cosmos and and the the cosmological
being has put certain things in us
because of our ancestors and it's just
complex and convoluted and confusing but
basically you have three what they call
doshas three heat you know CU they
believe in elements so like water Earth
you know same as in witchcraft exactly
so it's that that is describing that
then mudras this is specifically you
know yoga for the hands um and then this
is the guy that I was talking about um
that Osho who took over a county in
Oregon and so he collected what he did
is he went um through all the religions
and all the continents in the world and
he sought out what do other religions do
in order to transcend and go into the
spirit realm and so he collected over 2
I think 68
meditations um and so this book was
given to us for us to you know take in
and teach to our our our students um the
yoga sutras that would be pan jali and
know the father of Mo modern yoga and
then this is more about drishti this is
about your your state of
mind um these are the mantras that we
were we were taught and so for people
who don't understand mantras are
incantations to the spirits and there
are requests they are first homage to
Brahman the ultimate deity in their
world um in their religion but a mantra
is saying I want to yoke my spirit with
you Atman you know um uh Brahman and any
other deity that I you know subscribe to
that I want to worship and so when you
read this like the first one om sarvesam
Sabas babatu you know um when you read
this it sounds peaceful the way they've
trans translated it let there be Health
let there be peace let there beess let
there be celebration but you don't
understand what celebration is in the
Dark Realm versus what God intended our
Sal look how subtle and deceptive it is
let there be who said that let there be
Genesis so you could read this as a
Christian and be like oh this is just
like you know quoting the Bible right
okay so I have a theory on this when God
created Lucifer um he created him to be
the the one that really told the rest of
the people about who God was right
that was his job right the lightbearer
and and so God and His purposes would
bring Jesus into his Council and Satan's
upset that he can't go into the council
with God and everything right and then
that that whatever they were planning to
do they told Lucifer Lucifer then would
have told the other Angels the other
Angels would have went out to the
creation and told everybody else right
so Lucifer is designed to tell you
something about God he cannot operate
outside of the way that God designed him
all he did was bent it yeah so he's
still operating like God intended him to
build he's just he's just Twisted just
Twisted says lead me from the are you
going to read that yeah lead me from the
false to the truth um from uh Darkness
to light from Death to deathlessness so
that's that whole theory of
reincarnation right but it is that's
literally like the story of the Gospel
like lead me from false to truth
Darkness to light from Death to Eternal
almost like the prayer that when they
ask Jesus how do we pray right you know
let your will be done yes you know peace
on Earth and you know same same thing so
these mantras are things that literally
we had to memorize and you had to open
every single class with this Mantra W
you know you'd have to sing this and the
reason is because you're setting the
tone and you're inviting the people who
you're worship or not the spirits not
people you're inviting the spirits into
the practice and the devotion because
you're about to do a seance just like
starting church with worship music
exactly and inviting the Holy Spirit to
be a part of your your organization yeah
so so um like I said 12 to 14 hours of
training you know
meditation um this is when we're doing
Theory so this is all the philosophy
that's involved in yoga um this is some
of the AAR this is for people who are uh
disabled maybe or elderly and they need
additional acutron like straps and and
blocks so they teach you to have to even
address that population W um this is
more of the same um so there are
inversions or different um postures that
are said to activate different chakras
so they're teaching you the ins and outs
this is me leading class um and again
this is this is when they're they're
teaching you um this is more like
um uh student Le and this is um you know
teacher IND this is all India wow and
like all these people are not from India
nope well two people were two people in
my in my group were from India but
everyone else was from
wow yeah so again these are my um
certifications so you know that I'm not
you know just pretending to say that I
did things um so that's my Core Power
Yoga um certification that's more of an
Ashtanga style uh this is the school of
yoga and meditation and this is holistic
yoga teacher training with an aortic
approach and this one is Yoga therapy
teacher training
um and so I was so into this these are
my kids and again they naturally
flexible too like I've never met anyone
who can put their knees together and go
that direction and go that direction my
kids were naturally flexible and so for
them it was easy and they would see me
practicing and and and getting ready for
my class you know cuz you you create
your own sequences and they would
imitate me and so here I am
indoctrinating my children right um so
this just to show you how devoted I was
and again I was teaching at the best
clubs um and and this this is like part
of the the the sun salutation series and
I included this because here you are
slithering like a snake on the floor
bowing down to the sun's iations exactly
and you're getting ready this is a
transitional pose but you're getting
ready to come up into the Cobra pose so
the serpent pose you're a snake so my
life was yoga from medical practices to
teaching I was sold out and in the far
left you can see me doing a an ayurvedic
treatment this is part of the Poncha
Karma you can see me holding my hands in
the in the mudras on the bottom that's
actually my mom um and she was getting a
bosy and bosi is where they put a
medical oil on your knees to quote
unquote rejuvenate it um here I'm doing
Corrections on a student here this is
you know yoga cooking classes or yo yoga
classes and cooking classes this is me
really studying and this is uh this was
required every Friday night we would go
to the beach and meditate at Sunset and
I had no idea that it was Sun worship I
noticed I had no idea picture right
there on your shirt there's a picture
one of the deities you're wearing the
God on your shirt everybody loves
sunsets we're just out there enjoying I
just you're not just super naive like I
as a Christian I had a collection of
statues I loved religious art even from
when I was agnostic I had candles of
Jesus and all this and when I became a
Christian I still had that because it
was beautiful art to me I love religious
art from I had Buddha I had goats I had
Jesus and all these Catholic things and
everything because I just thought it was
beautiful and I and somebody pointed out
and I was like I don't worship it it's
just art to me but I'm still inviting
that thing into my house it's still a a
beacon or you know some kind of signal
to the spirit world well I'm allowed in
he's got the idol but I'm okay to not
listen to what God Said I have no Idols
you know yeah so um I was just complet
ignorant that I was practing um
practicing spiritualism and so again you
could see me this one the second one up
top is um one of the structures in
Hanuman Temple the monkey temple and
below this is me at the monkey temple
after the priest took me into a back
room and and blessed me with a DOT on
your forehead oh and yeah with put the
dot and open my third eye so this the
third eye is supposed to be the seed of
knowledge but this is also the place
where God says this is our seal right
this is where fral our frontal lob isn't
the third eye on the dollar is that the
triangle and um you know like I said I I
this is not about the people of India
again I love the people I don't I don't
see a difference between me and them
just because they're Indian you can ask
any of my Indian friends they're like
wow you know more than I do about you
know India or whatever and it's really I
don't mean to sound you know like
someone who's extorting the culture or
anything that it has nothing to do with
that I love people period like I'm a big
mix myself so doesn't bother me um this
is one of the Yoga Nidra classes this
one of the meditations and she's using a
tuning fork on my forehead to open up my
third eye wow so so can you explain
quickly what is the third eye cuz I just
brought it up we're going to get get
okay okay I'm really curious you know
completely sold out this was this was
who I was yeah um and again I just want
to say I love the people has nothing to
do with it my point is that no one ever
told
me that I was participating in mysticism
then I never got that option to say yes
I'm in or no I'm I'm good right and and
again I see the people of India as my
brothers and sisters that God created so
it has nothing to do with the
people um and so how did my world come
to a complete halt where I started to
stop and really look at you know what
was I doing God allowed Co and in the
Stillness of covid and the extreme
despair you know I was let I was living
in spiritualism I was I was practicing
yoga I was um under the guidance of a
spiritual Guru I was doing ayurveda I
was completely in this this mystical
world but still claiming Christianity
and God said no and so when he shut down
the the clubs that I worked out worked
at I literally had to stop and look at
everything and dig deep because
everything that I thought was bringing
me peace had led me to just severe
anxiety um no sense of Peace
disregulated um de like I wouldn't say
deities but I would say demons in my
home um apparitions um spiritual
harassment um spiritual attacks
involuntary Kundalini I ended up in the
ER um uh one attack dropped me down and
um whatever Spirit was was banging my
head on the floor like for what felt
like 2 minutes and I could hear my
husband saying what's wrong what
happened what I screaming but I you know
I could hear you actually hitting your
head on the floor I could hear him but I
couldn't was taken over by the spirit
yeah I was taken over by the spirit and
when I finally was able to talk he says
I'm taking you to the ER I said they
won't believe me yeah my fear was you
know they'll probably write me off
they're not going to understand what I
some drugs yeah they put you a mental
health and I cried and I cried and I I
mean God showed me so many things and
the truth and so this is where I start
to see where this this oppression this
demonic oppression and why it came did
you ever have any discussions with other
teachers did they have these kind of
similar experiences with all the
teachers I knew were depressed so I
wasn't I wasn't about to start talking
to them about my life really and it's
not a judgment but all the teachers I
knew I didn't know a single happy
because why people get into this is to
get centered and calm and this and that
and it's like to hear from a teacher
themselves like yeah this didn't bring
peace no I think people just become
really flagma and they're just very like
they they're they're okay with the the
state of this deep Darkness because it's
karma you know it's it's reincarnation
and and if we don't cleanse ourselves
and work it out in this lifetime then
we're going to be 10 times or a thousand
times worse than the next and so you
subscribe to this lie and you live in
this torture and you justify it by the
doctrine
it doesn't make sense have you ever
heard of the guy Steven bcars yeah so
when when I'm hearing his story and your
story you guys were very prominent
figures and and had a voice in this
community and I just praise God that he
got your attention because think of if
he never got your attention how many you
an evangelist for Satan yep basically
how many people would have been like
well blessing is a Christian she does it
well yeah I was yeah I was raised
Christian but you were a Christian
throughout the yog oh yeah I didn't I
was I was deceived I didn't know that I
was serving another god wow um so yeah
so Co it was a blessing in disguise and
God allowed it and it it really brought
me it he he leveled me I mean just I was
not myself and I went straight to the
Bible and thank God for my like my niece
because she was there she was the only
practicing Christian in our home seven
days Adventist my husband and I have
different faiths we're both Christian um
like I said you know my yoga Community
everything just basically was done and
he started to unveil why I was
spiritually
oppressed and so here you see how I had
all these Idols in my life and I didn't
even realize it and he literally starts
taking them all out of my life one by
one and he starts to let me see what is
really behind all these things that I
was
practicing
and the source of truth and the
authority is for me and for the whole
world whether they know it or not is the
Bible amen and it says you shall not
have or excuse me you shall have no
other gods before me you shall not make
for yourself a carved image any likeness
of anything that is in heaven above or
that is in the earth beneath or that is
in the water under the sea or the Earth
excuse me you shall not bow down to them
nor serve them and I didn't realize that
I was doing all of this and I didn't
understand why this was even a
commandment really you know because I I
mean I I had some experiences I did go
to Catholic School um for junior high
and College University and I saw these
things and it felt really uncomfortable
in their churches but I didn't really
understand the complete significance of
it and this is where I think it's
important that in order order to
identify the counterfeit you really have
to know the original Doctrine and so the
Bible is that it's the
authority so the whole point of this
isn't that I'm picking on again I'm not
picking on Hinduism because this is just
a small capsule of all the other Pagan
religions I'm just more familiar with
this one so I can speak on
this and so I take you back to the fall
of Lucifer Isaiah 14 so we get to know
why is this even important how you are
fallen from Heaven oh Lucifer son of the
morning how you are cut down to the
ground you who weakened the Nations
that's super important remember that for
you have said in your heart I will
Ascend into heaven I will exalt my
throne above the stars of God I will
also sit on the Mount of the
congregation on the farthest sides of
the north I will Ascend above the
heights of the clouds I will be like the
most high so you see a progression of i
i i and Satan declares his goal and it's
to be like God which God Yahweh thank
you so the great controversy really is
about after Satan gets ex expelled from
Heaven it's basically all out war
between he and Jesus and that is how the
last 6,000 years have played out and so
I will give you an encapsulation but
before we go there Revelation 129 tells
us the Great Dragon listen to the
terminology the names that they give him
the Great Dragon that Serpent of old
called the devil and Satan who deceives
the whole world he was cast to the Earth
and his angels were cast with
him so what I found in all of my
research studying world religions
including Hinduism is that the
counterfeit gospel is basically the do
doctrine of deception and there's
basically eight principles that I found
that every single one of them have and
the first one like I just showed you is
reincarnation the second one is that you
will be as God so whether you're talking
about like the Yuba epha this is like
the um uh people who were brought from
from Africa through slavery and ended up
here um and and they were practicing
it's still a prominent religion amongst
um epha believers they believe as well
that the the spirit reincarnates they
believe that they will be you know like
God and that they just need to tap into
this these chakras they use the same
language um you know they need to have
idol worship um they they have the
counterfeit God you know Satan presents
himself as Brahman or Osho Osuna Mar um
these are just different the univ main
yeah the Universe um the cosmos you'll
also see Angel worship you'll see nature
worship and you'll also see ancestor
worship and why that's important is
because it's the glue that holds it all
together if you don't have answer
Worship in this what ends up happening
is you'll just be scared because these
de demons won't be able to present
themselves you know in a way that's
comfortable in the form of your dead
ancestor oh I see see so so Robert cini
um has written some books on the on how
to influence people in fact some of the
top companies in the world um subscribe
to his like six ways of of like
basically the the strongest tie you
could ever do to influence someone his
family
mhm using that same method to influence
people it's like you're going to trust
your family why why are spiritualism why
is the family showing up I mean in your
case you want to you want to you know
reconnect with your
dadad why is that experience so strong
because if if they're weren't that piece
then they would just scare the Daylights
out of you you would have a clear
understanding that this was somebody's
lying to me yeah but if they can say oh
well I'm your sister that passed away in
that car crash and
and they know all the details they look
like them they sound like them they I
don't know maybe they smell like them
they know everything because there's
monitor the Bible tells us there's
monitoring Spirits right there's there's
these these these a third of the Angels
were cast out and they are Immortal
until Jesus comes returns in a second um
uh appearance but the the reality is
without that none of this would make
sense to us none of us would be
comfortable with it yeah true so
the big question is how could I have
practiced yoga Without Really knowing
that I was involved in Witchcraft and I
think this spells it out um in the
garanda samita it's one of the ancient
texts um uh like the scriptures for them
in the Hindu Faith um the ASA or
position of the body is described but
which technique or method to follow
while in the posture is not mentioned at
all this is because the Sedana or
scripture is extremely secret skipping
down practice an effort is made to
change the activities or process of the
body and the chemicals produced inside
the body even if this is achieved by
everyone who practices it there will be
those who do not understand what is
happening to them for this reason it has
been described as a secret process
secret process so it's secret on purpose
on purpose right and take note it's
saying we're trying to change the
process of the body we're trying to
change the chemicals produced inside of
it wow that's a problem because today if
you have a chemical imbalance what do
they give you all right chemicals
chemicals to correct that imbalance so
you really got to be concerned about
this stuff so what is Yoga when when I
was this is something they hammered in
me when I was in in India and it's yoga
n in the yoga sutas patali writes
yoga and it's yoga is the sensation of
the modification of fluctuations of the
minds so in other words you need to
empty your mind you need to get all of
what you know any kind of uh discernment
you have you need to clear it out so
that we can put in what we want and
isn't that exactly what God's asking for
us to do we need a new mind right we
need a new transformation it's like the
devil is literally looking at what God's
doing and going I'm going to do the
exact same thing but over here he wants
to take the place of God so he wants to
do the exact same thing and that's
exactly what he deared you know search
me oh God and know my thoughts try me
and know my heart and see if there be
any wicked way in me and Lead Me On the
Path Everlasting that is exactly this
Doctrine he's saying I'm going to search
your heart I'm going to and in fact
follow your heart you know and um and
he's going to say uh you know empty your
mind because I am going to try you and
I'm going to lead you on this
reincarnation path that's
Everlasting so this is Pan jali the
father of modern yog yoga you know he is
basically um the like I said the modern
um they call him like the father of the
of of yoga body of a snake he looks like
a snake to me so he absolutely is now
there's a lot of Mythology people don't
really there's no birth records for him
I mean she's just kind of like this
mysterious figure and they say that he
was you know existed somewhere between
the second and fourth Century um after
Christ's birth and he is The
Reincarnation or the Incarnation the God
in Hindu religion um he is half snake
half human and the mavali patan jali
sits on his tail with seven Cobra heads
so it kind of looks like a shell on the
top but it's actually seven um Cobra
heads above him and these represent
omnipresence um what I really want you
to pay attention to though are these two
uh figures here Sun worship you have a
star and you have a crescent moon and
that's the Hallmark of Pagan worship and
where do you see that exact star you see
it as part of the Jesuit logo that exact
star it it it came into being during the
Dark Ages when these different
Protestant reformers came out and the
Jesuits were called in to be almost like
a like a secret service today exactly to
counterfeit the Protestants they would
Inc infiltrate yeah infiltrate
Protestant churches and trying to people
turn people back to paganism and the
Roman Catholic Church um and so
obviously like we see a lot of the and
I'm not speaking against um Roman
Catholic people I I was baptized as a
baby in a Roman Catholic Church my
grandparents were Roman Catholic their
entire life my grandpa still alive is
still a Roman Catholic um I'm just
pointing out their hearts are pure yeah
exactly there's so many beautiful Roman
Catholic Christians I'm just pointing
out like what we can actually see and
this is just his history you can just
find it y i i I bet you if you went back
in time I mean this is probably the
symbol of Babylon this is the symbol
we're going there we're going there
exactly these these demons have outlived
everybody else and they're just putting
their stamp on different cultures and so
when you look at this you find out that
yoga is actually religion and if you
break it down it says haa yoga ha means
the Sun and th means the moon ha yoga is
also known as yoga ASA and the prim Ary
goal is Kundalini Awakening the serpent
now remember what he looked like right a
serpent right right and then so this is
that yogic Awakening and just like you
said if we go back in time what do we
find we find the same symbols with
Ishtar inana Venus the morning star or
it's also known as Lucifer son of the
morning in the Bible her head so I'm not
sure about what's on her head but she is
the main deity um within you know the
Babylonian and Pagan worship during
Biblical times and so you find her in
Mesopotamia Mesopotamia Samaria you find
her all over spread through the Middle
East you find her you know she's just
repeated and reinvented and so you'll
find that with many of the different um
the different gods and so you'll also
see her star in that form in modern day
and you'll also see it in this
form yeah people aren't just going to
spontaneously come up with this stuff
guys right right there is an author
there is an author you can't have this
kind of threat of consistency through
history and they're not be some sort of
remember they didn't have technology the
way that we have it they didn't have
internet so I could literally start a
religion and a cult right now and I
could have a an adherence somewhere in
Egypt and they would be worshiping with
me that's not how it went down back then
but here's the beauty of God you can
look at the Bible and you can see
through these different cultures
thousands of years different things you
see the golden thread of how God worked
with all these people and it's still the
same today for us those truths are true
back then as they are today and the
devil's just counterfeiting this
constantly wow so again biblical
accounts you see the Sun and the Moon
worship you see that Bale you see you
you see that you know he his his emblem
was the sun um and then you also see
ashth the moon and he's named many
different things um these are the
scriptures that relate to this count and
so as we know in the Bible you know it
talks about how God is is telling or or
excuse me Paul is telling um the
Israelites those who are basically you
know becoming Pagan and such he says you
know you're you're rejoicing in these
Idols you're creating these these cakes
for your your goddess you know and so
these are all the rebukes that that give
the depiction of what was happening in
biblical times so yoga is an is ancient
mysticism and nature worship um so you
see basically that what Kundalini
actually represents is the sun and the
moon coming together and so they believe
the sun is in the base right in the
crotch in the crotch basic at the at the
coxic bone in the genitals basically and
that it there's a there's a channel that
runs up the middle of the body and that
these snakes need to connect intertwine
and once they they meet at the top you
have this enlightening or this Awakening
and
so it's symbol it's it's symbology but
it's it's it's also um what they're
practicing in the spirit literally and
theoretically so what are those chakras
those those little circles that you see
going so those are supposedly energy
channels so as the snake the Kundalini
serpent Rises up the spine it hits every
one of these circular zones and when it
hits that zone you're going to hear a
certain tone and you're going to you're
going to feel a different like jolt I
find it kind of creepy when you say that
you hear a different tone as if like the
spirits are speaking oh it's music I was
thinking like maybe like the spirits are
speaking to you like so when I had my
Kundalini experience um and I didn't
understand that was being worked on me
with my Guru um we would did these
undulations and these you know breath
work this pranayama and um
I felt it immediately in my gen you know
genitals this overpowering Sensation
that feels orgasmic but it's Cosmic like
it it it goes Bey it feels like it's
going Beyond you and then as it climbs
up and hits different points it
literally makes a different sound but no
one was touching you nobody's touching
me that that is scary and then it hits
your head and then you're transported to
this very for me it was a black
completely black place and it was quiet
and it was it was peaceful but it was
oddly pitch black oddly dark oddly and
that's interesting because it starts
with the sun and it goes to the moon
like light to dark yes and so they
exactly you're very perceptive less
light to dark and so the practices also
to invert so you see that he's literally
turning the gospel upside down
wow enlightened wow so here's Su
namaskara so a lot of people think that
the the first um series that they do is
just a warmup in a yoga class but it's
actually called suya namaskara it's been
translating into English as Sun
salutation because it sounds a lot more
friendly than the direct Sanskrit
translation to English would be sun
worship and so suria on the far end that
is the solar de de deity in in the Hindu
Faith um and then these are all the ways
that you you know praise and worship
that s that deity and this is Shiva Lord
of yoga and Lord of dance you can see
that the serpents are worshiping the
disc in
Egypt isn't that interesting the orus
that's what that snake is called those
are cobras and then you can see that
yoga was also practiced in Egypt oh wow
and Shiva has a moon next to his head
there is the snake there is the Trident
you know like this is what I cuz I was
it was so fascinating when I edited that
episode with
Raj yeah who who pointed all this out
that there's so many similarities of
Shiva with Satan and these are just some
of them oh we're going to get into it so
from whom did yoga
originate Lord Shiva among the great
deities of Hinduism most personifies the
practice of yoga you will see the
picture of him from a temp in at a
temple where he Seated on and tree of
knowledge and sha is a god of knowledge
and so he's crushing the male child
there ringer Bell male child and as you
can see there's always a serpent with
him and uh then there's always a
trident a pitchfork a trident as you can
say and then his feet as you can see are
Bine feet
Bine oh okay so like C is that say c
like ba or something and most of those
temples of dam Muti form of Shiva they
are built facing the South because he's
a south facing creater in other words
the devotees have to face the sides of
the north I will send the sides of the
north above the clouds be like the most
high so when a person is practicing yoga
they are linking their mind with
[Music]
shivas that came from The Book of the
Dead yep Book of the Dead wow and so the
Tibetans also have a book of the Dead
wow and the Bible has the book of The
Living exact life yeah why serve a god
of the Dead when you're you know God is
living so that's what you're following
you're following a practice of death the
whole goal is to get you to kill
yourself and that's why these people
that the darkness is is is okay a death
and it's a death reir you're only going
to re why wouldn't you want to die you
know so as you were just speaking we're
going into the moon uh symbology that
you see in the actual uh Shiva and so
Chandra is the name of the moon it's the
moon deity and you could see it on top
of shiva's head that woman that's head
is popping out of his if you notice
she's actually a serpent so that's him
in a state of Kundalini oh wow and if
you notice his face he's kind of smiling
and his eyes are closed yeah and you can
see that he has a crescent moon at right
between his eyebrows he also has the
Chandra right up on his head and then he
has the snake on his side called basuki
Naga and he's the serpent God and he's
he's supposedly someone who in the Hindu
mythology this deity was um uh very
devoted to Shiva and didn't allow him to
get poisoned it's there's a lot of
convoluted mythology but anyway so the
snake stays with him but it's like the
snake is on the brain the snake is on
you know coming out the snake is like
literally behind him the force behind
him wow and so this in yoga is ARA
chandrasana Half Moon pose and it
venerates the moon so you cannot
separate yoga the physical practice from
the worship because this is this is the
form of that y this is the form of that
deity you cannot separate it you're
you're channeling you're talking to that
de you're saying oh you know Warrior
Lord whatever that that deity is I am
paying respect to you I am your devote
there's no way around it and then this
is another version of
Chandra um and he's writing or she's
writing in her Chariot which in our
culture became Santa Claus with the
reindeer maybe I don't know it could be
it could be because you do see this you
see this this deity in all almost all
the religions um in the uh in the in the
East and also in um Greek mythology you
see I don't remember the name but you
can find
this feels a bit like the red pill blue
pill it's like up if you yeah well it's
like if you take the pill you have to
take this action and by taking that
action if you remember that scene from
The Matrix what it says is what does
this do and he says it disrupts the
input output signal so that we can
pinpoint you and then find you and it's
like that's what this stuff is doing the
action is allowing the Demonic world to
P you making that choice and then
they're able to come in exactly so these
are some more uh postures that are
really sought after postures you know
because they're pretty let's just be
real they're pretty to look at but when
you actually know what AAP Raj pasasana
excuse me mermaid variation of King
pigeon is you'll see that it's a Hindu
god it's a pigeon um and it's basically
worshiping the goddess of lust and
passion right yeah I don't think it's by
chance that our world is obsessed with
yoga pants at this point no right no I
mean there's a reason why that those
kind of clothes are worn during that
kind of an activity is it really does
bolster up the idea of lust right it is
EAP
rajakapotasana is hence um an activation
of the manipura chakra and so all of
this has to do with like Awakening A
Certain Spirit and the Kundalini spirit
is a sensual Cosmic Force you know that
increases supposedly fertility and
sexual arousal and
Enlightenment wow want all that and then
you have lord of the dance pose there
are different variations this one I'm
I'm I'm basically doing somewhat of a
bind I'm taking my foot and putting it
in the in the uh Bend of my elbow but
oftentimes you'll see it where someone's
grabbing their foot with both hands
behind their head and it venerates again
Lord Shiva the Lord of the Dance the
Lord of
yoga um Satan and so you know you move
on to aneli mudra a lot of people even
we do this as Christians we we'll often
go oh thank you and you know we don't
realize send little praying hands yes
praying we don't realize that this is
one it's a mudra it's another way of of
you never seen the Bible about put your
hands together and yeah I've never
really thought of the Emoji like that
before why isn't it like this cuz isn't
that they do have another like this oh
interesting have you seen that but that
yeah that maybe honoring whatever Faith
does that kind of a thing like Muslims
or or whatever but yeah so you you'll
see that none of this stuff is is by
accident these are symbolic gestures and
they facilitate the flow of energy um
and they really that energy is spirit
it's it's not like taking a Red Bull and
all of a sudden you've got you know more
energy we're not talking about that it's
think when you hear energy think Spirit
yeah um half bound Lotus pose tree pose
um venerates the tree um and the goddess
parva the wife of
Shiva um and she's the embodiment of
shaki so you'll notice that these
deities have more than one name and they
have different incar reincarnations and
different avatars you know so that's
that's something that you have to pay
attention to wheel wheel is supposed to
be this pose um that that basically it
opens up all the chakras and so it's
something that you do toward the end of
your practice and so usually if you're
about to have a situation it could come
there at the peak when you've you know
opened up yourself because I mean if you
think of an animal in nature not that
we're that at all yeah you don't expose
your belly you don't and here you are
completely Belly Up exposed yeah in a
very vulnerable state yeah and that's
the one that you saw in the Book of the
Dead that the Egyptians were doing oh
yep good and they'll even drop down to
their elbows or they'll grab their
ankles in that position um and you see
it in in you know like gymnastics as
well but gymnastics isn't isn't this
stuff it's the same as like I do leg
races for my abs it's not the same thing
yeah no not at all so yeah again
anything that you see in yoga it
venerates either a
deity um an a element of nature that
they draw power on that has Spirits in
it
or it venerates a past Guru so you're
also praying to dead people wow yeah
which according to the Bible is NEC for
instance this one kinasa this flying
split um both feet are elevated and
you're balancing on one elbow and it is
venerating Sage kinasa so he was one of
the first five monks and um he was a sar
he was a a disciple of sartha gatama who
is Buddha and a lot of people don't know
that Buddha was an actual person who
lived and died and was buried he didn't
become an ascended or a Divinity until
500 years after Christianity wow
interesting yeah they changed the
doctrine because they saw that people
you know the Bible did reach Asia and so
they saw people being swayed by the word
and they're like whoa whoa whoa we need
to counter we need to C yeah so
headstand this is like the goal in yoga
like everybody body's like whoa I really
want to do a head you know a handstand
or a headstand and while we're thinking
about it transactionally like in terms
of I'm going to be able to get more
likes or I'm going to be that cool
person in class what you don't realize
is that you've just turned the gossip
gospel upside down like what you were
talking about the Moon and the Sun so
much of what you're saying is like like
making my mind go over you know the
Bible tells you to stand up who can
stand in this day like like to stand in
that face with God is very difficult and
what they're doing is just up and you're
working so hard at these these Feats
right and you're practicing and you're
swallowing and ingesting this this
foolishness sorry that's just demonic in
nature just to be able to do these
things not realizing you're
communicating with Spirits this is this
is not good so tying it back in you know
the Sun and Moon Transcendental
Meditation so what we just saw saw with
the headstand or the um arm or hand um
stands is that this is a posture where
you will become still and be aware of
the breath um this is where yantra of
aasawa the water element you visualize
the bright pure refreshing taste feel
your own connection like there's just a
lot of language that's basically telling
you think of the moon and the you know
we know that the moon does have an
effect on tides and the in the ocean and
so they're basically telling you and
visualize that and realize that there's
energy and power in this right and bring
it into the center of your awareness
flip the world upside down make the moon
prominent and bring the sun down you
know which is I mean why would you
do that but here you see again the this
is in Egypt Sun worship and you also see
the cow right the Bine you see um ishar
or ashth in you also see this symbol in
Roman coins you also see it on the cap
of the Catholic priests they wear it as
well
um and you also see it in um the Lima
you know the more Western ult Alis crley
yeah you got
the and you can see
Theo and the Hindu Hindu symbol Brahman
H super into this kind of stuff this is
where he got it from this is exactly
where yeah you know I think why God told
us in the second commandment not to have
graven images right and and it's because
he could see through time that this is
going to get used and and you know
whether God said it and don't do this
and the devil knows that it's wrong and
so now he's using it but this is his
form of communication this is his way of
stamping going this is mine yeah and the
thing to also understand is that
Sanskrit um is a spiritual language it
was it was invented specifically for
this purpose and again they keep telling
you about how secret it is right it's a
secret it's a secret
um so yoga is religion and a homage to
the Hindu deities yoga is a moving
liturgy or moving meditation that pays
reverence to over 330 million deities
okay and that's just the conservative uh
figure that they give out that everyone
agrees on and um you know when you think
about what you're doing you really have
to pay attention in yoga it's not just
about the physical posture again it's
about the breath it's about the finger
post it's about the way that you set
your intention or your mind and even
there's there's an internal Focus that
they want you to be aware of to steal
your mind and quiet it and then there's
an exterior point of focus so there's
there's this in just complete blackout
that you have to be in the state of like
mummification MH wow you know and and
the promise is you'll get God
Consciousness and so these are some of
the deities within the Hindu Pantheon
again I cannot put 330 million of them
on here but what I can't understand for
the life of me is why anyone would
worship someone who is as
murderous say as as C you know cie is
here um but they just look evil you know
stepping on somebody and killing them
and like smiling and laughing with horns
I mean it's like if you just kind of
observe an they they believe that you
know anim animals excuse me are sacred
and it's like I have a puppy and I love
her dearly but I would never bow to her
I would never create a temple for her I
can see that she's a lower being worship
of the creation yeah so there's a focus
on worshiping the created instead of the
Creator would you pay attention to that
hat too and have you ever seen uh down
here yeah have you ever seen a pope wear
a hat similar to
that fish and you just notice that
they're just disfigured you know
completely disfigured people um half
either half male half female you know
hermaphrodite or
transgender um they'll be half animal
they'll have extra arms it's just wild
they're all kind of always holding
something to as like a distraction tool
yeah you know what I mean it's like here
pay attention to this and this and this
and this and this even here you see the
you know the star the hexagram yeah so
there's it's all messages telling you
look this this is this is dark stuff
this is not you know Bambi you see
bamb was that right there again that's
that's the Moon Goddess that we were
just talking about
Chandra um so what is
Hinduism yoga is Hinduism yoga is an arm
of Hinduism it is religion so when we
talk about Hinduism we have to
understand that it's a religion with
over 330 million Gods it's also the
world's third largest
religion and when you put that in
numbers that's 1.2 billion followers
that's a lot of people lot um Hinduism
is a manifold system of thought marked
by a range of philosophies notice that
the Bible tells us that we are to be
beware of philosophy right that we
shouldn't be just listening to
conjectures and and hanging our faith on
that right um it has rituals
cosmological systems astrology
divination pilgrimage sites uh theology
metaphysics mythology vtic rights yoga
mudra agamic which is Tantra rituals
that's the sexual realm of yoga uh
Transcendental Meditation possession
animal and human sacrifice and idol
worship I'm not saying everybody that
does that is a Hindu does human
sacrifice but there are sects that do
believe in that and some sex will sex s
e CS not SS okay sections yeah sections
um do do will will sacrifice somebody to
get what they
need um so one thing that I really
appreciate about Pandit um uh pseudo
Pandit is that he's he has a great
program on is it amazing discoveries and
he talks about why even though he's from
India why he chose Christianity and how
he you know was in in inquiring mind and
he held this up as one of the ways to to
see if you if this is something you
should hang your faith on and so he says
it's not him he's quoting someone else
he says one must listen to the claims of
the document under analysis and not just
assume fraud or error unless the author
disqualifies himself by contradiction or
known factual inaccuracies yeah this
religion is riddled with known factual
inaccuracies and contradictions MH so
here we see that the doctrine
includes henotheism which is one God out
of many so you can pick the god that you
want right polytheism you can worship
all the gods you know that are available
pantheism which is God is in all things
so everything is sacred right um that
Apple that you're about to eat um that
cow that's in your farm you know
everything that's so strange because I
would would I be eating God yes because
then you are
contradiction doesn't make any sense um
then there's pantheism which is um God
is the universe so that's that whole
Cosmic and universe language that you
hear it also includes agnosticism so
people who claim they don't have faith
but they can still be a part of this
Faith system um it includes atheism so
yoga is atheistic in nature right they
don't really believe they don't really
believe in God they believe they are God
so it's kind of it's different um
there's monotheism worship of one deity
right and I don't see how one Doctrine
can have all of these different things
unless you're trying to catch you're
casting a broad net and you're trying to
catch everybody so in other words it's
basically relativism you know
universalism too whatever is God to you
is God to you who am I to say right the
God in Me salutes the god in you so they
Namaste exactly so it's contradictory
full of known factual
inaccuracies um so who is the Supreme
Being in Hinduism and you've heard me
refer to him already Brahman and they
call him the Ultimate Reality they say
that he's the cosmos the universe but he
also comes with other deities but the
top three deities are the ones that you
hear about the most because it's the way
to con convert
Christians and so they talk about um
let's see uh there's the three the top
three are Brahma the sustainer Vishnu um
or sorry Creator Brahman the sustainer
bishnu and the Destroyer Shiva so that's
just like a counterfeit Trinity right
exactly wow but they don't believe in a
trinity that's just the three that you
hear that's that is the most there's
like five at the very top from what I've
studied and um but yet each one of them
is a incarnation of itself MH if that
makes sense so it's really Satan and
then Satan's like mhm but then his
little Minions that want to be just like
him or no he's just like you know but
there's also this side of me oh
interesting and I'm going to call him
Vishnu and then there's this side of me
and I'm going to call her Shakti and
it's this and it's this and so it's kind
of like I'm going to cover all my bases
because as many people as there are on
earth one of these have got to hit right
exactly yeah maybe that's why he
identifies as androgenic you know it's
like you know whatever perverting what
God Said right marriage is between a man
and a woman so he's attacking that so we
come to what is hath yoga and basically
it uses the physical body the anamaya
kosha to influence and and gain control
over the mind that's the whole intent it
has nothing to do with you being
physically fit um and these are the
different limbs that they
use um and again you ask can you
separate it clearly no you know the yoga
prod
pra excuse me tells us that the goal of
all yoga practice is to awaken Kundalini
shaki so when you're doing yoga it's
it's a it's very narrow-minded the goal
is to experience this this Awakening so
and Awakening is what because I I know I
think I heard from uh Eric um Wilson who
we did a documentary with the dragon
reviewed and he was a former um karate
moral martial arts instructors he said
that that meant possession yeah right
yeah it is so what they call samade or
they call Mosa it's like you're being
liberated from your mind and you're
being united with the
Ultimate Reality which is
Brahman so in other words you're being
possessed yeah um and then here we are
New York Times bestseller sad Guru says
Kundalini is mind altering and you know
he says that it's it's it it's able to
change the perceptions and change the
chemicals in your your brain as your eye
is awakened which is interesting because
uh in Revelation talks about the dragon
will deceive the whole world through
sorcery or pharmaka and that's what
phakia is is mind altering yep and we
see how fast yoga is growing Y and how
you know it's really taking over the
world and it's deceiving a lot of people
even Christians are getting involved
yeah so there is a link for anyone who's
interested to see what Kundalini looks
like like I'm not going to click on it
here um but it's very like it looks like
demonic possession like what you would
think like the Exorcist and you see it
in a lot of churches charismatic
churches you'll see the same thing the
same what was the name of that that
documentary that that that um put put
the calini next to the people in the
church we actually oh I see yeah when
video like Pentecostal oh there was a
name for it it wasn't like kolini waking
it was like a yoga uncoiled or something
like that oh I don't know but we have a
video on it look up the law of
attraction or uh tongues in the church
put yeah but in this particular video
you see the guy who is basically um he
he's he's a sorcerer and he's you know
manipulating this woman with his fingers
and he's controlling The Serpent and
she's undulating her eyes are rolled
back so you'll see that version you'll
also see the version where it's um itic
you'll see them looking like they're
performing an act of of you know and
that's yoga mhm wow yeah um and so why
does he say it's dangerous he says
Kundalini Yoga in its Essence is the
most dangerous form of yoga when things
go wrong they go seriously wrong in ways
that you can't fix it and this is
someone who teaches it practices it
promotes it right this is not not like a
Christian this guy is one of the like
biggest group gurus right now um out
there I think that there are certain
demonic entities that get invoked and
they are literally crazy like I remember
um Roger mono talking about there are
certain classes of of of demons that
when they were told they could not
return back to Heaven they went crazy
and they're the ones that are likeah
right if you invite invite that in
there's no getting them out it's like
because encaps being encapsulated in
your body is like heaven for them y you
know you have to think about that you
know cuz it's Vengeance toward God and
it's also wow I get to you know do
something take you see this in the Bible
where where there was this man who was
possessed and it was only through Jesus
power he was there and said go and leave
this man and the the demons entered a
group of swine and they fell off the
rocks and so it yeah I can see that
being dangerous and it's only Jesus and
through his strength that you can be set
free from that possession so also points
out that there's two types of Yoga he
would never give yoga the Kundalini Yoga
to a person who is like raising a family
so all those moms at home that are you
know taking time out to do yoga you're
really putting your family at risk um he
says we teach people who live in family
situations a different yoga there is a
certain other type of yoga we teach to
Aesthetics which by the way none of us
are like none of us are living
in some desert you know completely
abstemious of of everything and devoid
of bathing and you know that's none of
us so we don't fit in either
category um so here's a case study a
case report of a
19-year-old it's okay but she basically
shows up in the hospital and she has um
signs of Awakening of the Kundalini and
it manifests itself through her physical
and psychological psychologically and
some of the the the things that she
reports is that she's feeling this vital
energy in her body you know and that
there's it's coming from an outside
force and she just feels like she's the
recipient and so she describes it as
feeling feeling vibrations of Prana in
different parts inside the body feeling
electric light currents flowing up and
down the nerves experiencing Bliss
having Divine visions and getting
inspiration and insight she's 19 years
old she she found yoga on her own and
got intrigued because of books and stuff
that she saw online so she started doing
it and then before long she was having
an a Kundalini experience and so the
Bible tells us let no one disqualify you
insisting on asceticism going on in
detail about Visions puffed up without
Reason by his sensuous mind and that's
exactly what yoga is it's all about the
mind and it is about you know perceptual
experiences that fool you and think that
you're one with God or or you have
become God and puffed up without reason
that's what you're talking about like
when you're doing this stuff these
people are still depressed they still
but yet they they're like I got my yoga
mat I'm enlightened and all these things
they have a pride that comes with it but
for what without reason they still have
no hope they still have no peace they're
still depressed no and and it's
important to realize that all of these
gurus who are quote unquote ascended
masters I'm not going to say a th% is
this this is true well I can say a th%
they all died but I can also tell you
that most of them are extremely
perverted especially the ones that have
introduced yoga to this world they have
class action suits against them for
child rape um molestation sexual
harassment you name it um they're just
uncontrolled with their need for
material things um like the guy Beam
Beam had like I don't know 20 to 40
rolls-royces something like that that's
so weird like they get away with it
because when somebody goes off to India
or whatever and this Guru he's touching
all over them they're like well just
just trust him you know he's like the
guru he's the guy you know well even sad
Guru um he has uh women who have come
forward but for some reason he's still
out there very prominent and so back you
know in the 1500s and late or early
1600s um desaris wrote about um visual
perception and the role of the pineal
gland and the pineal gland is some is is
it's basically in the middle of our
brain and it looks like a pine cone and
that's really a symbol that you see in
the occult um and you also see it in the
Catholic church right so there's they
they really want to affect the pineal
gland to have these perceptions and so
desaris wrote about it and he had
basically he got got smashed for his
idea but then Helena BL uh what's her
name Alie blotsky where is she here she
is um she argue that the pineal gland is
that which the Eastern occultists call
Daka the the the Divine eye or the third
eye and to this day it's the foremost
organ of spirituality in the human brain
and so she's saying regardless of
whether you think it's scientific or not
the reality is that we are getting
Altered States Of Consciousness we are
getting this you know know um outof body
experience and these gifts because we're
activating this gland and actually
science now currently says that the
pineal gland's primary function of
letting in light and darkness right
that's the main thing that it's supposed
to do it's supposed to basically allow
us also to regulate our sense of time um
The cirian rhythms um is also what
they're now calling the third eye they
say that in in this one study it says
the mystical psychedelic compound found
in the normal brain not only does the
pineal gland regulate the secretion of
melatonin which is a sleep inducing
hormone Studies have also revealed that
the pineal gland has naturally occurring
DMT and so this is what people are
calling The Spirit Molecule if you've
heard that you know um it's it's a way
to make the brain create its own
hallucinogenic formula let's say DM is
natural and it's released at birth and
death and when you dream but they can't
really prove that and they can't
pinpoint how the mechanism is but
remember it said in the yoga the ancient
uh Doctrine it said we want to change
what in the body the the the function of
the mind and the chemicals in the body
so they're on to something oh yeah
because there's people that you know
they they tell their testimonies when I
started yoga I start started doing
meditation and then I could start going
into alter stes of Consciousness and
then it's like then I wouldn't even they
would take 20 minutes sometimes and they
say I could get to where I could
instantly be in an altered state there
was even a a video of a lady who was
sharing that she was abducted by aliens
right after meditating
yeah Vision well most of the time in
fact I think that's what came out of the
documentary that you made most of the
time it was because of the meditation
that they saw the aliens and there's 400
documented cases of people people coming
out of that
illusion by using the name of Jesus so
that tells me that it's not this real
physical it's this something that's
going on in the brain that's probably
tied to this you know Ivan Raj whom you
guys had you know he also showed that
one of shiva's avatars is an alien and I
don't think that's a coincidence and
that the avatars are all blue and Avatar
and it's like throughout history you
have all these blue things yeah the
demons are messing with each culture
this is their way Hollywood of making it
familiar to us y so that we just accept
it so how we see in in in past um
societies we can see that here the Eye
of Horus right um in the front of it you
can see a snake the Cobra and that is
translated to the third eye because the
the serpent is what gives you that
knowledge right and so again you see
Shiva you know and and Chandra and shaki
and his little friend so this is going
back to that same case study um and it's
just talking about you know the girl's
experiences and how she was feeling and
she she's saying that she's hearing
voices and that they're telling her to
follow orders in her day-to-day
activities and so she no longer is in
control of her body she's now um just
completely you know mummified or
zombified and something else is
orchestrating her life for her she no
longer eats she no longer sleeps she's
just up doing yoga and pranayama
breathing what wow so over a months she
also expressed to have experienced
Eternal Enlightenment and she initially
well excuse me her family members also
believe these experiences to be the
outcome of her Yoga
practices however the change in the
patient was not seen as a deviance but
as an impact of yoga practice until she
stopped eating speaking interacting with
others and was found Frozen in sustained
postures requiring medical attention and
that's when they took her to the ER oh
my so this is what people are playing
with and they don't realize it according
to Rama Kundalini is thought to contain
latent energy and memories that could be
personal and
transpersonal the modern way of
understanding this is saying that
basically you are using the unconscious
mind and in '94 one of these prominent
gurus sananda he wrote the spiritual
basis for Saraswati says that some
people who have awakened Kundalini get
in contact with their unconscious body
and see inauspicious feroci elements
such as ghosts monsters Etc or get other
perceptual phenomena phenomenal
experiences so that's what you were just
talking about aliens and and a lot of
people we're seeing a lot of this like
people have had the experience with
aliens are seeing their dead relatives
and stuff like let's say I boarded a
ship an alien abducted me I went on a
ship and I saw my dead Grandpa and stuff
like it's always this connection with
familiar spirits the um necromancy
communicating with exctly and this is
that same thing just in a it's it's
been fixed for the culture yeah and the
story that he's promoting wow and so
this girl ends up basically you know um
impaired judgment absent of insight she
had they they had to actually diagnose
her with schizophrenia wow yeah and so
she was catatonic subtype she was she
was then prescribed uh resperidone and
lorasa Pam and by the way she never got
cured she's these are actual case
studies and that case study came from
India from a medical Indian Journal so
it's not even someone who's against you
know what I mean it's it's of the
culture um so let's talk about cities
because this is something people don't
understand when they're doing yoga
they're getting these quote unquote
gifts and they're called cities the
Paranormal Powers the success of hath
yoga depends on attaining the 18 cities
and the cities are associated with
psychic or paranor paranormal abilities
there are great there are eight great
ones right and they say basically you
can get anything out of thin air it's
called
manifesting love attraction Oprah all
those people exactly you can achieve
Clairvoyance telepathy Clare audience
where you hear things that aren't you
know there um psychokinesis where you
can move things with your mind so you
know where's my phone and I just move it
over here um you can also levitate you
can shrink your body to an atomic size
teleportation ability to live underwater
so that brings me back to like these
these people like
Marvel but think about that guy who does
all those crazy magic tricks and stunts
and he's underwater Oh yeah David
bla some of those people yeah I mean
underwater for an un
like there how How could somebody
humanly do that angel oh it's like hours
it's not days you can't hold your breath
for hours your body would you'd be
devoid of oxygen it just makes me wonder
like how Satan does that you know I
think it's all the illusion of power and
like you know like God when he sends
somebody into Vision right they're like
not breathing and I mean there's there's
Supernatural phenomenon that are
happening there Legion could break
chains and's like oh wow that was pretty
powerful and a lot of people are going
to believe it if that that that
Supernatural thing happened and during
this thing so he's making these
Supernatural
contious things happening I mean they
really they I mean if you can yeah do
those some of those things I mean that's
not that's not natural you got to you
got to attribute that whatever he's
telling you is is true to something he
will tell you where you got we can get
some of this from the Bible so um you
know ability to break chains and stuff
teleportation MH Satan did that to Jesus
he took him up to a mountain took him up
to a high Temple and all that but God
also used that power for the the um
Philip yes when he sent him to baptize
the the unic Candace yeah so we know
that there is a supernatural world but
these are these are quote unquote gifts
which are actually curses that you're
getting and they also say that you know
again and this this is the girl attested
this the case study it attested it says
that can free yourself from Hunger
thirst other bodily disturbances hearing
and seeing things far away moving the
body at the speed of the Mind assuming
any form one desires entering and
controlling people and and animals
that's what makes me think of those brei
shape shifters you you name it like this
is what modern movies are made out of Y
and we're just getting massaged yeah to
it's preparation so this just goes over
Raja you know yoga it's basically aanga
it's employing the eight limbs of pan
jali
all the things that I touched over the
beginning you know um and the thing that
happens is that yoga is very addictive
and people start to think oh that's the
power that I have but we have to be very
clear that's not your power you know
these are powers that are coming from
the Divine universe and it's his power
it's Satan's power and so when you yoke
with him he allows you to share in it
but he can
turn yeah he can easily cause you a
problem and they go oh you want some
healing well um you know he'll tell his
buddies hey stoping crystals on there so
you think whatever you're doing here is
actually healing you but it's just them
removing and giving you the problem not
exactly and this is just an example you
know the very first Asa they tell you
sidasa you know when you're sitting
crossle you know with your hands and
anelim mudra they say it opens the doors
of realization it's um then the the the
second one says the description of
subasa that's corpse pose when you're
lying like a dead person touches The
Fringe of the psychological plane to be
traversed in the attempt to reach the
metaphysical goal and then B banasa
which is the Cobra pose um I didn't have
a picture of myself doing that raising
where you're laying on the yeah on on
your stomach and you're arching your
your upper your thoracic Zone um is is
basically an Awakening of the Kundalini
so from physiological there there is
here a rise to the spiritual field this
is always with witcraft there's no other
way to look at it and it's such a
counterfeit like when you come to God
right what's the first thing you want to
do when God showed up to anybody in the
Bible any example that we have what did
people do they fell down and they like
you know fell on their knees right so
sitting on the ground is like the first
submission part of it then I'm going to
die and then I'm going to come back as
your thing and the thing this is what
you asked about chakras and so you can
see that each one of these has an emblem
on it you know and each one represents a
different zone or organ in the bottom
body but these aren't the only these are
the seven main chakras that are involved
in in in Kundalini Awakening but there's
others um what what's up with the lotus
flower the Lotus they say that when
you've reached zatti when you've like
opened up your brain and you've
connected um that it's like a um a
thousand petal Lotus and the Lotus has a
has a great symbology in both Buddhism
and Hinduism because it grows in dirt
like mud and it comes up this beautiful
flower and so they really play on that
like but but then like you've achieved
Darkness not light like the moon not the
Sun but exactly darkness is light in
this world wow and remember the
scripture says that ever call Darkness
light light and darkness Bitter Sweet
Sweet
Bitter so again mudras what are they
it's sign language for the spirits so
you know they're they're nonverbal modes
of communication with deities you're
playing with you know inviting the
weirdest of things these are all my
hands and I can't believe that I was
able to do that first one how many
pieces of art have you ever saw in any
sort of art art art from 16th century St
Jesus Buddha did that always has this
one and that one how many celebrities
have you seen this all the rappers and
everybody else has do I mean dude it's
like literally the
same exactly that's showing you and
stamping who their God truly is and who
they're connected to so are M mudas just
postures you know are they are or are
they or are they just gestures or are
they actually postures and an invocation
they are each finger represents a
different element and you'll see that
they're into the elements right there's
that whole nature worship well the same
thing happens in the occult right with
the pentagrams and the hexagrams and
each you know angle points to a
different element so when you start to
make different combinations with your
fingers you're invoking those energies
which are actually Spirits so the one
that you asked about um pranam mudra
that you always see Jesus in Gnostic art
you know in Catholic works you'll see
him using that and the reason is because
pran mudra it's said to be the one of
the most important mudras because it
it's it's going to give you life and
vitality and and awaken things within
you and then the middle one the one that
looks like the K fig uh finger
Tri or the trip six is gion mudra and
that's the elements when you're touching
your fingers like that you're touching
space and air and again many people are
seen doing this even in um Hindu dance
you see a lot of this and it supposedly
awakens the crown chakra which is the
snake exactly so 666
snake all interated they all interated
okay so we did project on the elements
and and really witchcraft is a
counterfeit for God's Miracles right
something Supernatural happens you got
two options you can either say something
did that God did it or in the Witchcraft
it's like if I just mix these right
elements together if I say the right
words together if I do the right things
I'm now in control of that Supernatural
thing so it's taking the power away from
God and going now I'm the one that did
that and it's weird to see all of this
in history and then bam it's in all
these cartoons all these
we did a whole that broke down all these
witchcraft cartoons that do this kind
ofu and the thing is that you notice
that you
know if you look at the Egyptians they
were said to be you know one of the most
technologically advanced most you know
genius societies they believed in these
same deities and they were destroyed so
how is it that that God is right I just
I just think of it that way you know and
you just see that same m message just
being transferred and repackaged over
and over and over and over again and
this is exactly what that is it's like
they've tried it with cultures
throughout history right and they watch
the culture go down they perfect it they
tweak it they try it again and it's like
you're seeing these same threads of
things that's why Babylon Egypt Greece
Rome all those have these exact same
similarities but I like that you brought
up the fact that none of those are
around because none of those kingdoms
like Daniel's 2 statue are going to last
it's going to be God's they're going to
be taken down so what's the let's put it
all together this is like an then this
is coming straight from the the the viic
text okay so it's coming from them I'm
this isn't someone else's words this is
their scripture and it says sitting in
sedosa so that's that pose you know um
with your knees cross close the two ears
with the two thumbs the eyes with the
index fingers so this is another mudra
you know that you're about to start
doing um the nostrils with the middle
fingers the upper lip with the four
fingers and the lower lip with the
little fingers draw in The Prana Vu by
khakim
mudras and join it with the a aav vayu
contemplating the six chakras in their
order let the Wise One awaken the
sleeping serpent godis Kundalini by
repeating the Mantra hun and Hansa and
raising the Force Kundalini with the Jaa
plac them at the Thousand petal Lotus
the crown being himself full of Saki so
being himself fully possessed wow being
joined with the great Shiva right which
is the Destroyer which is the Destroyer
the god of Lord and or the Lord of dance
and yoga let him think of the various
pleasures and enjoyments so remember
your Sumptuous mind yeah let him
contemplate on the union of Shiva spirit
and shaky force or energy in this world
being himself all Bliss let him realize
that he is the brah you are God so
there's something really interesting
with the whole sexuality right nowhere
in the Bible does God ever tell you to
have a sexual experience outside of
marriage right so think about this God
designs this wonderful beautiful thing
that we all share that you are giving
pleasure to someone else right it's this
ultimate Act of others focusness right
what the devil's done he just tweaked
with that he's just Twisted that no you
can do it by yourself you can have the
pleasure that that that you want and
look at that you're having this
pleasurable experience outside of of
someone else or whatever and you're like
literally doing it in a demonic way
pornography in your mind but with the
demon doing it
y dude this is just crazy and this is
the thing these are the things they do
not show you when you're getting
certified this is stuff that I had to
research because God was like I need you
to understand what you're doing is not
right it will lead to damnation wow so
I'm going to speed up really quickly it
just talks about what is the the concept
of sin in the Hindu culture in the
religion and it basically they only say
there's seven of them and it they say
that you know we fight against them but
the more that you fight against them the
more you're going to have this this
Dharma and this Karma and so the first
one is lust which I find interesting
because the whole Kundalini thing is
lust so what are we it's again
contradictory um then they say it's
anger you know you should never be angry
but all their gods are angry right um
they say greed you shouldn't be greedy
greed manifest law of ATT you're on it
um and then they say attachment we
shouldn't be attached to anything but
but isn't doing this whole practice a
form of
attachment one with everything right and
then it says um sense of ey so the ego
right they always want to kill the ego
we were made in the image of God
therefore he wants us to die so what if
this is literally everything that you're
going to get if you play around with
that it really is you're going to get
lust you're going to get anger you're
going to get greed you're going to be
attached to things you're going to have
a sense of is addictive it's Pride like
I got yoga mat and all that prideful and
so they talk about how do you get rid of
sin how do you repent well they say you
can recite the
pasum 40 times Bible talks about
repetitious prayer right exactly vain
vain repetitious prayer it says or you
can observe Mon ofata it's a it's a vow
of silence so they'll just not talk you
can observe um Dana which is Charity or
Danna excuse me and also you can do it
through Aroda which is a ceremony of
adoration or you can do it in by bathing
in sacred uh Rivers like the Ganges and
that would the easiest one you know but
God is telling us don't Worship You Know
You Paul tells us anything that you do
in terms of idol worship you're
basically giving it to Demons it's not
of God and so he urges us to make sure
that we present our bodies as a living
holy sacrifice the same way that this
yoga practice is to present ourselves to
their these other deities God is saying
you owe me that too and you don't have
to do all this bizarre stuff you could
just read the word and walk in my path
instead of being silent just ask for
your sins to be forgiven and whatever
you ask is will be forgiven look at the
counterfeit that's happening right and
the Bible says there's one mediator
between God and man which is Jesus
Christ Jes pray pray to Jesus boom yeah
not any of these other deities and so
these are just examples and it turns
into ancestor worship because that's one
of the ways that you can get rid of
sin um and so these are all the
different rituals that they'll do you
know AA a fire ritual um Paka um and and
basically what they're doing is they're
they're having this this Seance and they
are nourish they're asking their past
ancestors to nourish them and to bless
them and protect them wow and so there's
all these rights and things that they're
doing to venerate the dead and remember
like I said the stuff doesn't work
unless there's an angle of ancestor
worship and you know wow then it it
becomes real to them because you got
skin in the game and then on the topic
of of um the the the concept of sin
there is in in southern IND India the Y
yal yalama excuse me cult and it's
basically a cult of divine prostitution
so in Hinduism there you can every path
is a path to Enlightenment like if you
you want to be a prostitute go ahead and
be that I got a God for that but they
literally say don't have lust
everything's contradictory but that's
the LIE is is they're telling you yeah
that they're that's what they're getting
away from but it's it's literally
leading you into and this is just a
different there's three different types
of these girls and if you want you can
go to YouTube this one's family safe you
can actually watch this and you can see
that I think it was BBC News did a a doc
like a quick little 10 you know story
about it and what's interesting is this
is what they did uh with bail Worship in
in the temple yeah like CH children were
offered up as sacrifices and the
children were sent to be child
prostitutes in the temple same same
story just different time different
place and so that's just the
um the link to be able to go there and
so this just goes into exactly what
they're doing and the priests are
actually involved in this so the women
the young girls um are basically
auctioned off to different underage yes
wow all ages underage they're auctioned
off to basically pimps and these pimps
support them and some of them remain
virgins until a specific time but
there's a dowry that's involved like
it's a very corrupt system and um they
also have to prostitute for the temple
like what you were just saying um wow
there's you leave it to man they're
going to somehow turn it sexual
and even the men dress up as women um
again if you want to check that out to
just fact check me please do because I'm
not here to desecrate anybody I'm just
here to expose you to what this religion
really stands for so we're tracing the
lie all the way back and and it it
really boils down to the biblical
accounts that we've already spoken about
you know um you know Satan getting cast
out him saying you know I'm gonna be
like the Most High um these are all
across the world now these this isn't
every single one this is as many as I
could find or put on a page but these
are all the different mythologies and
religions that are present or path that
involve possession wow and it's
institutionalized as religion so this
whole concept that you'll be
reincarnated that there's Angel worship
that there's you know um dead ancestors
that we need to venerate like you even
see it in the cabala with you know
Jewish mythology and again we we we know
that Christianity there are branches
that believe in that I was about to
point it out like you put their Sola sub
scriptura so like those Christians who
stuck with the scriptures don't have
that but other who stray away from the
scriptures do what I think is crazy is
sitting in this seat of Earth's history
we have the history to look at and then
we're looking at the Bible we're going
now that makes sense wait now that makes
sense everything's there we just it's
open to whomever would dare pick it up
and read it wow it's there's he doesn't
hide anything where this stuff it's
hidden it's all secret yeah nobody gets
deceived if you're Solo scriptor exactly
right so you already talked about this
you know in Mark you know Mark 5 um it
talks about you know possession um the
Bible again talks about the state of the
Dead The Dead Know Nothing they're
resting until Jesus comes so don't be
deceived and mysticism is a big part of
this you know there's a lot of ritual
writs and notice that the Greek uh word
muo is properly shutting the eyes and
the mouth to experience mystery wow
shutting the eyes do you remember the
description that I just gave you he he
had the person contain every shut every
orifice and every
percep in order to get this Divine Eyes
Nose
wow and at the same time they're doing
this other thing and I think it's called
V mudra where you're squeezing your anus
wow yeah so you're shutting off all you
know
these areas of yes wow in order to get
and again how is it that you're getting
a revelation when you're shutting your
eyes and mouth it doesn't make sense but
that's what it is fa faith comes by
hearing and hearing by the word of God
so we need to hear we need to read we
need to see to make sense and so these
are just some of the ways some of the
terms that you have for this mysticism
MOA Nirvana Ascension atun Yahweh
buddhahood nosis and then the different
ways you know cuz it's all about
perception it's about disturbing the
chemicals in the body so these are some
of the Psychedelic drugs the meditation
practices um there's also a lot of
nature worship and you know God talks
about the fact that I am not nature I
created it you know but I am I am the
Lord I do not change I do not lie where
these deceiving Spirits are full of lies
constantly so we know that we have to
you know keep our eye on on the Bible
and Jesus amen and so this just goes
into Lucifer son of the morning and
these are um accounts and statements
from actual occult members and it says
there's no contradiction here for set is
the Egyptian devil and Shiva is the
Indian God of destruction both name set
and Shiva are also listed in the Satanic
Bible as none other than Satan wow Shiva
and then Helena botski affirms now we
have but to remember that Shiva and his
Palestinian Bale or Malo and Saturn are
identical so it's just the same God over
and over and over again Shiva same same
the the aurus in Egypt the serpent that
then becomes you know know um something
that we see in di dionisis which was a
Greek god and again the sex part is
there you know sex orgies drunken right
and and it says drunken sex to bring
about demons to actual human sacrifice
wow yeah and so the M the mother of
Alexander Alexander the Great Olympus
she was a member of this cult and it was
said that she would sleep with snakes in
her bed wow and have sex and all that
wait with snakes yeah
wow this is the serpent exactly glycon
you see all the you know it doesn't
matter what Pagan you know uh religion
it is you see the same Gods repeated
over and over just with a different mask
and it's like glycon with a lamb's head
yeah it almost looks like Sid swept Sid
swep or whatever it's
like um the orus again is just another
version of that you know um Horus the
Eye of
Horus um this gives you knowledge the
serpent gives you knowledge it opens
your third eye he's the one that said
eat this fruit your eyes will be open
exactly so here there's that Focus again
just it just just differentiates between
when you see the left eye and when you
see the right eye one is the sun one is
the moon you see it again here in Shiva
the Destroyer you know these are just
antonyms for the same God you can also
see that same symbol in Islam you can
see it in the hamsa you can see it in
the Eye of Providence within the
Catholic faith oh wow you can see it
again here you know and and as you
mentioned the dollar y you know it's a
symbol of an occult presence and you can
see it again back in the biblical days
these are the repres representations of
those Gods you see the the Sunburst star
and you see the the U Crescent Moon MH
um these are just all the forms I mean I
could go on and on you can even see it
here that egptian God you see the the
horns with the the solar disc you see it
as the third eye of Shiva I mean in
between the bull horns and yeah it just
doesn't stop you see it in Shriner's
logo you even see it in you know the the
the emblem of Islam wow you see it on
top of their temples MH right um and and
you know I'll go just wind it up here
because I could literally keep going
over and over and you just see these
gods they just morph from one culture to
the next to the next to the next and
each each one dies and then you see the
ey and the the triangle the
hexagram and alist Crowley he has on
sun yeah wow and again the transgender
nature of the Gods right you know you
see it in bth you see it in Shri Debi
you see it here Shiva you know it's it's
all over the place
right and it just doesn't stop the
occult and serpents and the moon and the
crescent moon and the and the and the
sun solar disc it just never ends it's a
Common Thread through everybody if you
look at the Hindu version of of Shiva
and you go to the Greco Roman version of
Isis doesn't she look just like Shiva
yeah if you go to Isis from Egypt is she
not the same as the and if you go to the
bull the Holy Bull wow uhuh yeah and
it's even been morphed into Christianity
where you have um Jesus with a disc
yeah that Christ Consciousness again
these are all the the places Satan has
fed this lie to wow so I just really
hope that people would learn that you
know idolatry yoga it's it's a dangerous
practice it's not limited it's an enter
it's yeah I mean we can go on for hours
I'm just going to sum it up here and
just hopefully you know that again I
love every single nation culture people
it has nothing to do with that yeah I
think we need to make a statement
because um we've been having some
messages from very sincere Catholics
about some some you know sometimes we
talk about you know the idea of
Catholicism and connect it with um you
know when we show up these these show
these Pagan symbolisms and and and that
is because like we said before there you
can look at up in history that that
paganism and at the time Christianity
was merged that out of it came
Catholicism but we don't hate on
Catholics like I said I I I went to a
Catholic Church I went through the
childhood communion I had the rosary
didn't know what to do with it but I was
in that church for a little while my
grandparents were part of it my mom came
with me and took us there and so we we
don't hate on Catholics we don't hate on
any you know we mentioned something
about Pentecostals in here we don't hate
on them like you said we don't we all we
are wanting to do is reveal the truth so
people can come to solo scriptura Jesus
and the scriptures alone and worship him
in truth that's just what I want to
point out that we we love all people
from all religions amen it's the
doctrine that's going to lead us to a
misunderstanding yes and it's going to
rob us from our right the inheritance of
the Kingdom exactly and we should be
Watchmen we should be looking out for
each other and we should not just look
to to the form of godliness and think
that that is our Salvation it's not and
so even for me if if I found something
in my faith that was not right I would
bring it to light because I would hope
for correction the goal is to testify of
Christ not of a aberation or you know
denomination yeah a denomination or yeah
you know here's your version of it
that's not it it's it's the Bible and
the Bible alone yeah so I hope you're at
home if you are listening to this and
maybe feel offended please don't we
really mean this in a loving way uh and
a caring way to just reveal to people
the truth which is Jesus the way the
truth and the life amen amen and that's
why the show is called light exposing
Darkness because we care so much about
deception we don't want people to be
deceived I think all of us here have
been deceived at some point in time or
even opening up about that thank you so
much blessings for sharing your personal
story nobody can deny your own Journey
this is what you've discovered this is
where um God has brought you where
you're at today and I know there's a lot
of people that are going down this road
and so I pray that this has been eye
openening it's been eye opening to me to
see all this stuff and um I just pray
that if you know somebody that's even
considering going to yoga because they
have back pain or whatever show them
this information so they can make a a an
intelligent decision whether they should
do this or not there's many different
ways to help your back pain or whatever
there's many different ways to do
stretching without involving chance and
prayer and all these things we are
trying to um show people how to not be
deceived and so if you enjoyed this or
if you were blessed by this episode
please give it a thumbs up please
subscribe if you're not a subscriber and
share this with your family and friends
if you want to support this ministry you
can go to little light studios. TV and
you can do a donation there you can go
to lightwear do shop and get get a cool
t-shirt that helps you wear your witness
and that watch And subscribe to little
light kids little light kids as well
it's a new channel we need your support
to help that Ministry grow so that we
can train up children in the way they
should go and if you want to see more of
this because you just did a whole series
we will put a link to the series in the
description below and people can get in
contact with you because this is
something that I believe you guys need
to share if you don't understand this uh
please watch all of her series blessings
you will be blessed it's not just her
name you will actually get blessed and
um help us get this word out yeah we
love you we thank you we can't do this
without you we'll see you next time on
LED
live if you're looking for good
wholesome educational content for your
children subscribe to our new channel
little like
[Music]
kids
a
[Music]
oh
a